QUITE THE WILD RIDE, JUMPED
EARLIER IN THE SESSION BEFORE
COMING BACK DOWN.
LET'S BRING IN MATT EGAN WITH
THE LATEST, SO MATT, IT LOOKS
LIKE JANUARY'S WILD RIDE
CONTINUES, SEEMS TO BE A MARKET
TRADING IN SUCH A WAY THAT IF
YOU LOOK AWAY YOU'RE GOING TO
MISS SOMETHING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ALLISON, YOU
KNOW, NONE OF THIS IS NORMAL.
ONLY WHEN INVESTORS ARE REALLY
FEELING A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AND
NERVOUSNESS DO YOU SEE WILD
SWINGS LIKE THIS.
IT'S KIND OF REMINISCENT OF SOME
OTHER REALLY TENSE MOMENTS IN
THE MARKET, I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE U.S./CHINA TRADE WAR THAT IN
2013 TAPER TANTRUM, THE ON SET
OF COVID ITSELF IN MARCH, 2020,
NOT TO SAY LOSSES ARE AS EXTREME
AS THEN BUT JUST THIS BACK AND
FORTH ACTION IN THE VOLATILITY
IS STARTING TO LOOK LIKE THAT.
SO WE'RE SEEING ANOTHER DAY OF,
REALLY, OF REMARKABLE RECOVERY
ON WALL STREET.
DOW IS DOWN MORE THAN 800 POINTS
AT ITS LOW, UP 150 POINTS NOW IN
THE LAST 80 MINUTES OR SO, NOT
EVEN, HAVE YOU SEEN THE MARKET
TURN POSITIVE.
THE NASDAQ WAS DOWN BY 3%, MORE
THAN THAT, NOW DOWN LESS THAN
1%.
SEE CERTAINLY MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT I THINK ALL
OF THIS UNDERSCORES THE
UNCERTAINTY THAT INVESTORS FEEL
RIGHT NOW ABOUT RUSSIA/UKRAINE
TENSIONS, ABOUT HIGH INFLATION,
AND OF COURSE, THE FED'S PLANS
TO FIGHT INFLATION BY RAISING
INTEREST RATES.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR MORE ON THAT
FRONT TOMORROW FROM JEROME
POWELL WHEN HE TAKES QUESTIONS
FROM REPORTERS AND I THINK WE
CAN EXPECT MORE VOLATILITY THEN,
AS WELL, ALLISON.
>> DO YOU REALLY THINK THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE VOLATILITY EVEN
AFTER THE FED MEETS TOMORROW AND
WE HEAR FROM JAY POWELL HIMSELF
AT THE PRESS CONFERENCE?
SOMETHING MAYBE SBERSS CAN LOOK
FOR TO CALM THINGS HERE?
WHAT ARE INVESTORS LOOKING FOR
FROM JAY POWELL.
>> WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR,
PROBABLY TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
IN A PERFECT WORLD, INVESTORS
WOULD BE HAPPY WITH THE FED
SIGNALING A LOT OF PATIENCE WITH
RAISING INTEREST RATES, BUT THE
FED IS IN A TOUGH SPOT BECAUSE
IT'S GOT TO CATCH UP TO
INFLATION SO THAT'S NOT
REALISTIC.
I THINK THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM
JEROME POWELL THAT HE IS TAKING
EVERYTHING INTO ACCOUNT, THAT HE
IS WATCHING WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE REAL ECONOMY, THAT HE'S GOT
CONFIDENCE THAT INFLATION WILL
COME DOWN, AND THAT HE DOESN'T
WANT TO, YOU KNOW, COOL OFF THE
ECONOMY SO MUCH THAT IT ACTUALLY
THREATENS THE RECOVERY ITSELF.
SO THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANY
SURPRISES FROM JEROME POWELL IF
THE FED CAME OUT AND SIGNALING A
MUST FASTER PACE OF RAISING
INTEREST RATES, I THINK THAT
WOULD UNNERVE INVESTORS BUT ALSO
I THINK THERE'S A GOOD REASON TO
SUSPECT VOLATILITY CONTINUES
BECAUSE FED MEETINGS OFTEN BRING
TURBULENCE IN FINANCIAL MARKETS.
WE'VE SEEN TIMES WHEN THE
STATEMENT COMES OUT, DOW UP 2,
300 POINTS AND BY THE TIME
JEROME POWELL IS DONE WITH THE
PRESS CONFERENCE, IT'S DOWN 300
POINT AND SEE THAT'S NOT WHEN
WE'RE TALK BEGUN RUSSIA/UKRAINE
TENSION SO THERE'S A LOT OF
MOVING PIECES AND I THINK THE